all right guys bang-bang
I have Jeff here we've got a ton to talk
about you recently wrote a book and have
a bunch of really cool ideas I think
that people will be interested in
learning about so thanks for coming on
and doing this thanks a lot for having
me
yeah let's go right through your
background first because you are not an
author by trade let's start there and
and we can get into some of the ideas
yeah good call yeah book is not
something I wanted to write I thought I
had to write so I'm a technology
executive technology co-founder of
multiple companies I've started former
companies one of those companies grew to
a half a billion dollars in market cap
over over the course of 19 years and and
just a whole bunch of Technology boards
so sitting at the front seat of what how
technology is changing the world very
cool and in the book what was kind of
the genesis for why to write the book um
I looked I looked forward in what's
happening with technology and and how
it's bumping up against an existing
system that won't work in the future
and I said and I thought my kids won't
grow up in the same world I grew up in
the future will not look anything like
the past all of the benefits that were
provided to us I think will be stripped
away and the world will look very
different unless we get our heads around
what's happening for sure and so the
book is called the price of tomorrow
why deflation is the key to an abundant
future let's just start with kind of the
101
what is deflation and what is inflation
okay so and again people have an
emotional attachment to these they
shouldn't right it's just this the facts
of inflation is when your money loses
value and assets go up in price as a
result right because the purchasing
power of your money goes
for goods and services get more
expensive and deflation is the opposite
your your purchasing power goes up
because goods and services get get less
expensive and there's a whole bunch of
an emotional context to that it actually
has nothing to do with the facts and so
people will just blindly say deflation
is bad inflation that's good without
realizing it with inflation you're
actually saying I'm destroying the value
of the currency that's that's what you
were trying to so whenever when a
government has an inflationary target
what if they said we are going to try to
essentially make the currency worthless
or worth less would people be on the
street rising up and and they might
think so is but but it's I think it's
important to detach the emotion from the
facts and then you can then you can then
you can debate the facts and go better
systems so let's talk about inflation
first because that's obviously the
system that we live in today the fiat
currencies and kind of the economic
model help us understand like how
exactly does inflation work and then
what is the reasoning behind why we have
the inflationary model we have what's
the kind of defense of inflation well no
more on and I just it's provided the
world a lot of wealth right it's the is
we have in an inflationary environment
for a long time our parents grew up in
it their parents grew up in it and and
so on and it's provided the world a lot
of wealth but in that the assets go up
in price so if you borrow today with
money you borrow from the bank today
then with inflation your incomes will
rise over time and the money will be
worth less right and so you pay that
that money back later on with inflation
with dollars that are worth less and and
the asset prices rise a good example as
a house my parents bought their first
house for I think it was 69 thousand
dollars
and in the 70s that house is worth 1.5
million today I'm the death it was paid
back I think they took a $59,000 my debt
which was a lot to that time and and
they paid it back over time as their
incomes rose so that's that's the world
we live in and it's not bad
some people win more right the debt
holders win more and everything else and
it's not a and it's not bad but we've
had a structural break and it's not
coded the structural breakers technology
that has changed the rules yeah
and so the current economic system we
have was really built for the old world
right and so if it was built for the old
world maybe describe a little bit about
your thought process of life that
Industrial Revolution type world is
dying and what I think you're arguing
here is the fact that we need a new
economic model for the world were going
into right it's kind of like we had an
old world with an old economic system
that old economic system match the world
we're in now if the world changes to
this technology-enabled world now all of
a sudden you're arguing that we actually
need a new economic model for the future
correct correct and and if you if you
look at this you can see it everywhere
by the way it's all of the evidence
points to it but people are ignoring it
because they don't want to believe it
and and so so so give some proof points
you know it's probably the best example
that everybody has in their hand is
their iPhone or smartphone that phone
20 it was only invented they're not
quite 13 years ago right and and look at
the phone what's on it today just about
all your apps free right you use Google
for free ways for free it's all free so
you have the power power more than
presidents had 20 years ago 30 years ago
sitting in the palm of your hands and
it's all free it's a you can buy and by
the way it's not deflation bad free we
don't wait for when when the new iPhone
comes up there's a line around the block
to buy it even though you can get last
year's for next to nothing
of $20 a month and have everything for
free so that technology deflation is a
good thing right
our Google searches or in fact that all
of the platform companies from music to
Google to Amazon it's all they're all
created actually using that same same
example you know technology or you're an
investor in technology I'm very much
interested in technology and and it's a
good thing every technology executive I
work with is trying to do good in the
world and provide more efficiency and
better more abundance using technology
and that comes at the cost of jobs so
that's what's that that's what's
happening overall and it's accelerating
in the world
the only thing masking went is a massive
increase in debt and leverage where
you're pulling demand forward from the
future with debt that you can never pay
back in the future and so that massive
amount of debt and money and monetary
easing in the last 20 years to get
negligible inflation rates is a hundred
and eighty five trillion dollars to
produce forty six trillion dollars of
economic return in GDP
so when debt is growing way faster than
GDP you know something's wrong
right and and here's the thing this is
before kovat this is before everything I
predicted all of these these events
before that before they were happening :
accelerates the trend to technology
right can I take sodor it's the zoom
went from 10 million users to 200
million users and in a month how many of
those users don't need the same
commercial real estate when they come
back out of : and and and so how much
changes how fast this changes how fast
robotics is changing how fast AI is is
moving people that aren't in close tick
to technology don't realize how fast
this is moving and and our old systems
weren't built for that technology
deflation because when if you have
deflation
debt explodes in real terms you can
never pay it back so if you have if you
have effectively economy that's built on
massive debt creation and you allow
deflation you have to reset the debt and
that's a problem with the central
bankers all over the world are facing
they don't know what to do right and
because this system and so instead of
doing what you instead of facing the
facts
you keep papering over the facts and
every time you paper over the facts if
you look at the stock market rising
because because of your juicing defense
the feds taking anything off the balance
sheets it's not capitalism you're
picking the pocket of the poor and
paying the rich because asset prices go
up and and that leads to division of
society revolutions and Wars and there's
a reset in that event and know no matter
what yeah I think it's a really
important part where basically people
don't realize the inflation has an
impact on a portion of the population
but it also benefits the other portion
right I actually recently tweeted and
said every time that more money is
printed the rich people cheer because
they know they're going to get richer
right because those asset prices will
continue to rise all the time whereas
the bottom you know 50% or so of
Americans in some cases the bottom 90%
they end up getting hurt and they don't
even realize it so it's almost like
you've got one group that understands
the rules of the game and the other that
doesn't did you read Paul Volcker's
quote back back number of years ago he
said we've convinced it we have a whole
bunch of enormously rich people that
have convinced himself they're rich
because of their smart and constructive
and it's not that it's because you've
rigged to the rules of the game and and
and and by the way they're I understand
how hard this is from a banking policy
and everything else so let's what to do
that let's just use an example and
you and me in our own little economy and
it will expand it so let's say you and I
went to went went to school together I
decided to save money you decided to
come out of school and and borrow money
to spend lavishly right you bored 500k I
didn't I tried to say right and let's
call that year 2002 your your economy
what it looks like to everybody else
around you you buy a house you hire
gardeners everything else if you can't
pay back the five hundred thousand then
you have a real problem but if instead
of paying back the five hundred thousand
you borrow another million two years
later to be able to do that and then you
buy another house and everything else
you could never pay back the five
hundred thousand but you use some of the
millions but be able to pay back the
house the interest and some to buy
another house and then I as your friend
I go and rent one of those houses and
you and you believe and everyone looks
at you and says wow look at how much
success you have right and then you
can't keep up to that and you borrow
another moment but you buy another house
and then you think wow I'm gonna create
a business around this and you employ
tons of people and you all that leverage
is juicing returns and the asset prices
are going up the whole time I'm waiting
patiently thinking it's all a house of
cards you can't pay for any of it it's
all gonna come crashing down I'm waiting
for the day that it all comes crashing
down and I make my fortune with my cash
when when when the market resets but
what happens is I miss under and I miss
understand that the central banks are
part of that game right and the banking
system is part of that game and
everybody was fooled by all the jobs
that your gardeners your vacations your
boats everything else created and
everybody copying you doing the same
thing and all of that leverage pushed up
high housing prices and my rents kept
going up as well right I'm on the other
side and it looked like it was really
working and then 2008 it comes
and banks stop lending to each other
because they can't trust the balance
sheets all over the world that internet
connections are global the central
bankers think it's only subprime and it
explodes everywhere and and if they
don't save the system we end up with a
depression right that's what would it
would have happened in in 2008 of global
depression and that would have been
really bad um but the cost of saving the
system saves you and everybody else
whoo-hoo-hoo leverage the system and
kills me because my cash is destroyed in
value it's just a transfer of wealth and
it's a map and so we wonder why we have
the this insane amount of wealth
disparity and it's because we're gaming
the system
mm-hmm and I guess in that situation
then let's go to kind of the new
economic model right so we're well aware
that we're entering a new world a
technology-enabled world in that world
if we're able to switch from inflation
to deflation what's the new world look
like aha so this is gonna break people's
brains but but again that's why it's
hard to I think you need to detach the
emotion from the facts if you actually
if you could reset today today like
imagine a total reset you had no depth
in the world and you could reset you
wouldn't need as many jobs right because
jobs would fall at the natural rate of
technology deflation and things would
get lower and lower cost over that
course and you also wouldn't need a
massive social safety net to be able to
protect the people that fell out because
the natural course gravity would happen
right instead of fighting gravity and
pretending your lung to stop it you
would allow that to happen and and
actually capitalism would work perfectly
in that system because the people who
wanted to work more would create all
sorts of value and get paid more of the
pipe for the people that fell off that
treadmill because jobs are coming out of
society with robotics a
everything else people that follow
wouldn't fault fall and and not be able
to feed their families because their
savings would basically be getting more
valuable exactly and and and their and
and you exactly you're not you're not
distorting capitalism you know think
about this right right now with because
all that happened in 2008 forward now is
we papered over the problem we created a
way bigger problem right and now Cove it
exposed so the system is so much more
fragile now and so you have governments
and I talked about this in the book
remember I don't bow this in the book
before this happened right because it's
predictable no matter what there's
nothing that there's nothing central
governments around the world are going
to be able to do to stop technology
technological deflation nothing it's a
structural it's a structural difference
and it's it's like I use this example
quite often
it's like blockbuster 9000 stores not
saying Netflix because technology was
moving so fast and didn't see it at the
rate of speed of download speed would
change their economic model overnight
and instead of buying Netflix for 50
million dollars they headed candy aisles
to their blockbuster stores okay and if
you if you zoom up to what we're doing
what central banks all over the world
are doing we're adding candy aisles to
the blockbuster stores and and think
about this so you have your juicing
retreat because if you actually wrote
down the assets and this is important
policy decision to write and so it's not
good bad people there's a whole bunch of
people and in Twitter land and
everything else is saying all these
terrible people if you're in their shoes
and you look out and you see we have a
global depression coming or we can try
to keep this going this deck chairs on
the Titanic keep going you might do the
same thing right so the policy response
right now is
yeah they're not looking at the
second-order and third-order
consequences of the policy decisions
they're looking at right now
what do I do with facing this
unemployment rate and everything else
but by by throwing money with you so to
yesterday the Fed announced the 2.3
trillion dollars in essentially junk
bonds right and and that would look like
subprime that would have got the whole
thing would have gone to zero and so the
Fed took that off the balance sheet of
people that are that it created the
problem and and replaced fresh cap fresh
cash the result of that means the asset
prices don't fall like they need to
right so as asset prices are
automatically juiced and they they stay
high and they'll go higher because
you're destroying the currency
underneath and and then and then they'll
hold on to people left out of society
you have to pay them to to be able to
pay for those high asset prices in
rented and and so the amount of wasted
money
staggering on both sides of this
equation and you're driving this divided
socialism capitalism and both people are
talking about the system the old system
and all the solutions on top of it or
old solutions on top of it because they
have to know that it's a structural
change yeah I think part of this is
people don't understand how the system
works obviously but what you're talking
about here is in this deflationary
environment there's two things that I
think are really important so the first
is this idea that right now we ask
American citizens and citizens around
the world be an expert at what you do
for a living so whether you're a teacher
fireman investor you know whatever it is
you do for a professional living you've
got to be a professional ladder right
you've got to be one of the best then we
also say by the way you can't just make
money and hold on to that money because
ultimately that money will lose value
over time we're going to incentivize you
to either spend it or invest it as it
you can spend it right you can be
consumer and consume more
or we then say to you you either have to
become a professional investor as well
or you're gonna have to pay somebody who
is a professional to invest the money
for you and so what ends up occurring
here is the idea of saving actually
isn't nearly as valuable as it should be
right you're basically saving something
that's just leaking through the holes in
a bucket to something right and and so
when you move to a deflationary
environment what you can actually say to
somebody is the money that you are paid
if you save it over time you will become
wealthier you'll be rewarded for having
a low time preference and for saving
rather than be incentivized to either
become a professional investor or pay
something to invest your capital and I
think that just that alone changes the
way that wealth is distributed
throughout the world simply by taking
the bottom 50% and structurally putting
them at an advantage rather than a
disadvantage exactly and and capitalism
works perfectly in that system the the
so exactly so today instead of thinking
it as money think about it is I put a
pizza in the bank right so I can eat and
I go back to the and it's in four slices
and I can eat for four four days and
then I go back to the bank and it's in
six slices um and I can't I'm still
hungry
right I got I got my I got my pizza but
it doesn't feed me at this a bit of the
same I got what they they said that they
divided it and it doesn't feed me the
same and so if you think about what's
happening in our economy right that's
what's happening and in our economies
and so no wonder people are rising out
no wonder there
no wonder the bottom half is looking at
it things we didn't see we haven't seen
since the 30s right 20s and 30 the
socialism and how rampant that hole that
because the system right now doesn't
work yeah
let's talk about the transition period
between the inflation to the deflation
right so we can understand how the
existing system works we understand
here's a world that could work better
the transition is I think the part that
scares the [ __ ] out of most people right
yeah and so what in your opinion like
how does that transition most likely
happen and then what is the good parts
of the transition and then what are the
scary bad parts of it so so a cleansing
of the system is required right that
cleansing of the system is going to
happen one way or they up
that's if we keep doing what we're doing
currencies are going to break because
now it's just game theory and global
currencies and everybody's printing more
so if every currency is printing more
you've ruined the trust of what the
fundamental unit of value is and and if
you can't trust that trade trade
collapses and and and so and that's not
that's this that's a huge problem but
that's a small problem
the bigger problem of that is
politicians get elected with that and
and blame other people for creating the
problem which creates revolution and war
right you can see that in your political
in the u.s. political cycle today you
can see it around the world and it's all
caused from the same thing it's it's
people want to believe somebody and
they'll believe anybody it's it's easier
to say it's his fault rather than take
to say it's a structural problem it's
easier to blame somebody it's easier to
blame China it's easier to blame
somebody else and then as that starts to
happen and you you you have you have to
create a bigger rhythm is effectively
what that looks like and so if you keep
doing what we're doing that's what you
can expect revolutions and wars to be
commonplace I'm really ugly and and you
have politicians that take the the
bottom 50% and say it's not your fault
it's their fault and when that divide
becomes too much those assets will get
taken anyone's and they won't look ok so
so the the rich in that case are
deluding themselves if it can go on is
there'd be pitchforks in the street and
then now to move from country to country
that's it what the existing system looks
like if you allowed inflation to happen
if you just said full stock and so one
argument that's a bad bad outcome right
the other argument is potentially just
as bad an outcome and that left to play
let capitalism work and spin stop
propping up banks everything else and
let the system fail and Rickon reset you
would go through a world global
multi-year depression right and and and
there would be a lot of unemployment
there would be a lot of problems in that
so so because the problem is now so big
the solution there are isn't I would
love to say there's a real easy solution
and here's what it is I can't say that
right now and nobody can and the people
that are saying that or deluding
themselves right they're not looking at
for this from a first principle
standpoint or looking at this
second-order and third-order
consequences of the decisions but those
are the facts where we are and so I
guess in that environment so if you go
with the first one where there's the
Wars the revolutions etc it's not so
much one country versus another it's
basically the people versus the
establishment right but the problem is
it turns into look at the rise of Hitler
and the thirties right it was a friend
it was a fringe party that came into
power because there were bread lines in
the streets right and and that and that
happened because US called their debt
right and and they had to go into this
hyperinflation environment to get out of
the debt so they had to print money like
crazy to get over the debt and that
forced people in the street with no jobs
and they couldn't feed themselves and in
that environment people rise up and say
it's not your fault it sees people that
have the money is their fault and when
you've done that and that's not a big
enough thing to retain power you have to
create a bigger enemy outside your
country
so you're right the first order
consequence is rising up in the streets
right in inside countries second order
consequence is that's not a big enough
enemy to retain power and so you have to
it it's such a quick that it's really
predictable right we've seen it
throughout history anytime you get into
this this currency battles this is this
is what is likely outcome and it doesn't
need to look like that
um but there needs to be very critical
debate on the first principles on what's
changed to be able to avoid that to be
able to avoid bad outcome and I guess
then if you go to the second option
which is let the system fail right what
the bad companies get flushed out etc
the is the argument that they won't do
that because of the short-term pain that
is they are that's that's that's the
argument the the the short-term pain
name a politician that does the the
long-term good right it's it's really
difficult to to to to place a long-term
bet against how much short-term back
pain so that's that's actually what and
I know you're a fan of Bitcoin I am as
well um I hope I don't need it right I
really hope I don't need it but but all
of the data is supporting that I'm going
to write because if I need it what that
means this currencies have failed
everywhere and it becomes a new standard
and we have a harsh reset and it
explodes in value yes it creates a lot
of wealth for people that know that
earlier that are the tons of wealth but
the reset is so severe in the world that
it also creates staggering pain yeah and
I guess as part of that is Bitcoin the
only answer or is there something like
gold right that's just kind of more
sound money or maybe there's something
else like what do you think the
potential solutions are options are so
so as a policy response right now is a
and and I'm involved in this in Canada
but but in the you saw the same thing
Tim Cook has had
with the policy with the best policy
response right now would be where are
the jobs in the future going to be if
you if you're an individual country or
state or anything else where are the
jobs going to be and and double down
there instead of propping up the
existing system right make a huge bet on
where the jobs are going to be in the
future that bet is technology right and
and so technology is gonna accelerate
from here and that is where the jobs are
going to be but it won't create enough
jobs to replace the one that is there
destroy that's kind of the point so if
you're playing game theory in doing what
you could do for an in one economy
double triple quadruple down on
technology because you build it's a it's
the new they used to build roads right
the roads are now technology lanes right
the the backbone of that our world is a
technology landscape and that's where
and that's where the investment should
be going for the countries that do that
they'll come out stronger right but if
every country does that which is likely
it's pretty predictive countries did
that and everybody's competing for the
same scarce technology jobs and it's
gonna it but you're gonna have deflation
anyways like no matter what so from a so
that's would be the policy response that
could they could actually probably make
at least the money that you spend spend
make a bigger difference to your economy
and and and then you wouldn't naturally
prop up prices that should fall and it
would it would transition so you still
have you're still with the amount of
debt in the world is about and it
mounted debt in any economy you're gonna
still have to reset that debt at some
point and and that that reset a lot of
people are gonna be wiped out right a
lot of people that think that can the
debt can be paid forever by increasing
more debts could more debt more debt to
those people are gonna be wiped out what
happens to
governments meaning the national debt
and things like that where it's not on
the individual level Orica the the
individual corporate level it's actually
on a more macro scale something like the
US government's debt well that's a that
is the same thing it's so that's why I
say the game right now is in currencies
right and so so the it's moved from the
debt went from technology companies
become boom housing to asset bubble
after asset bubble after asset bubble
and it and that wasn't enough and each
time you needed more debt to replace the
problem created before because the
structure has changed right and now it's
just moved to currencies so that's
actually why bitcoin is a logical
progression because what is a currency
it like it's a piece of paper with faces
on its a and if it pumped you you lend
me a whole bunch of money right and I
can't pay you back but I have a little
magic printing machine that I can change
the nominal value that currency and
pretend to pay you back you probably
wouldn't do that again you probably
wouldn't lend me again right and so
that's what's happening of Ehrman's all
over the world you're starting to get to
you're starting to debt at a critical
point where how many zeros can you add
to this thing and still trust the
foundation of currency and you can't
yeah everything wrote something where I
basically said the magician has been
exposed right and it's this idea of like
the entire economy is built on the fact
that 50% or more of the participants in
the economy don't understand how money
works because if they did writes the
Henry Ford quote if they understood how
it worked they we rep you know revolting
in the streets by tomorrow right and so
I think what is happening right now and
I'm still kind of thinking through it so
don't hold me exactly do this but it
feels like the Federal Reserve is having
to explain the magic trick to the
national audience and what's interesting
to me is you've got you know 16 million
Americans give or take who have lost
their job in the last three weeks add
that up with the five point eight
million that were already previously
unemployed so you got about 21 22
million Americans that are sitting at
home no
jobs should be in the labor force
there's no sports on television right
and so all they can do is they can
basically play on social media they can
watch Netflix or they can pay attention
to Cove in nineteen and economic news
right and they're busy as a result yeah
and it's just not that much going on
right and so this is kind of like
primetime television is what's going on
in the economy and with the virus and so
right at that moment when everyone's
paying attention and also everyone's
fearful you then get the Federal Reserve
saying we have unlimited money we can
just print the money right we're gonna
print two trillion here to show you in
here here's another trillion etc and
what I think happens is all of a sudden
you're giving a crash course in what
money is and how it works to the bottom
50% that you never wanted to understand
how money works right you were counting
on them not to know it but now you've
revealed the magic trick to them and so
the the question that I think will come
out of this is something like wait a
second you can make as much money as you
want out of thin air why do I pay you
taxes if you can just create the money
anyways right and you start to get more
of these like populist type questions
where people start to just say this
doesn't make sense to me right and I
think that's kind of step one of many
many steps that eventually end up in
social unrest but it you know it's not
immediate but I do think that it all
starts with kind of revealing the magic
trick and having to do it on a national
stage and transparent because you're
trying to solve the short-term problems
yeah and I don't know I don't know even
so if you looked at primetime TV
do you think do you think anybody really
understands the magic trick I don't
think that there's any explanation that
what I think ends up happening is people
see wait a minute we're two trillion
dollars come from right and they're
almost like it's like being the
difference between going to a college
and sitting there and somebody saying
okay Paul the textbook and we're gonna
teach you you know line by line exactly
how this is theoretically supposed to
work versus somebody says hey you wanna
be a fireman run into that fire right
and either you figure out how to fight
the fire or you die and over time what
ends up happening is the people who just
learn by doing that's essentially what's
happening here right as you're learning
by seeing it actually happened
and so not everyone gets educated but I
think more people are educated watching
this then probably you know previously
by just going to school or something
like that maybe and that's why it shows
like what you do is so important right
now because because it breaks through
the it breaks through the clutter that
people are people are talking about and
and and and give some light to some of
the first principles what's really
happening and behind the magic curtain
yeah what do you think the the TV covers
that we're seeing right now good bad
everywhere in between I try not to I try
not to tune in and watch because because
I find I find it's all done for sound
bites and for and and and it's short
term and everything else I don't think
the right solution I don't think the
right thing to do in in is say what
would you have us do right and and still
make the wrong decision right so I
understand the problem right I totally
understand the problem I understand
where governments have created so much
money and they kick the can down the
road member nessam Talib's nessam table
was quote that sometimes preventing the
forest fire creates a bigger fire on the
horizon because they you don't clear the
bush and the dead bush so the next fire
it was way bigger that's what we're
doing right and so so that is not
solving a problem
that is making future generations pay
for a problem that is exponentially
bigger so what you have right now and
actually if you looked at the numbers
it's because creates such it's crazy you
technology moving exponentially and and
you know this but technology runs on
Moore's law which is an exponential
pattern and and even if more of this law
ends in a number of cycles quantum
computers the digitization AI is moving
so fast you could assume we're gonna
have an exponential pattern in
technology for a long time to come well
why that matters a lot I use this to
quote before if you fold a piece of
paper
50 times on itself at Ford 50 I've asked
this to tens of thousands of people and
most people would say it'll afford 50
it'll be 2 inches thick it fooled 50 if
you could economical that seven times on
itself but it fooled 50 that piece of
paper would be from here to the Sun and
and what you just did with your face is
I've seen that tens of thousands of
times and it's not a it's not that
that's it's just an exponential pattern
it's not I'm smarter the first time I
saw that I thought there's no way it
goes to the Sun I had to google it every
day to see it all human beings miss
exponential patterns we're gotta
everybody otherwise you would have way
more guesses that went to the Sun right
so in if you looked at the data so we
all are routed exponential patterns but
we have an exponential pattern
underneath technology it's it's it's
doubling at that rate and we're looking
backwards in time of technology and
making predictions on a linear scale
looking forwards and what's happening
right now in technology we're in this
steep steps right so you name a
technology company or in a technology
industry and what ends up happening in
the early folds you have this hype cycle
they call it the Gartner hype cycle
right give this a hype cycle because
people overestimate the impact the
benefit and and they and it rise tons of
money goes into that and then it
collapses but it keeps doubling and so
what ends up happening is on the first
fold of the paper it looks like nothing
and so tell somebody tells you it's
gonna on the second floor that's going
to be great so I can fold it looks like
nothing we're on hold 33 right now did
you take those analogs together full 34
doubles the last 50 years
and and and if you now compare that to
the debt creation it's a mirror image
the amount of debt to try to pretend we
live in the old world is rising
exactly lockstep to to the amount of
technology deflation that's ever and if
you if you add in the unfunded
liabilities so the social safety net
pensions and everything else in the
black pool should everything else you
would see it really clearly and and if
that wasn't bad enough right so to prove
the point that the old system won't work
anymore
that's looking backwards looking
forwards that's that's kind of what I
put in the book and a lot of people are
talking about right now this was
perfectly predictable right perfectly
predictable because they mounted that
needed right now to to keep to pretend
we still live in the old world is so
crazy it's so much more than even the
wildest predictions on Twitter are
saying and so at some point that breaks
yeah do you think that there's a world
where they recognize this and they just
let it break they let the defaults
happen and they let the closing or is it
just it's impossible for them to do that
because of the game theory yet now we're
- now we're playing with probabilities
so it's hard to say these the next
number of years gonna look very
different it's gonna break anyways no
matter what you do if if if there was a
global coordinated effort to say we're
gonna write off some of this a whole
pile of this debt write it today or a
whole bunch of people fail and we're
gonna have a new standard like Bretton
Woods where we can trust money again
globally the acquaint wasn't survive in
that we could create a digital Bitcoin
that was backed by all all current
currencies that the
could actually replace trying to trust
that would be and by the way I'm
personally long on Bitcoin so that would
not be that might not be a good thing
for that value right but but I don't
think that that could happen in the
today's trust environment yeah it's
almost like the things that they would
need to do in order to be successful
there's just no way they'll do it
because it would involve such incredible
global coordination among countries they
just don't get along in in a world that
the the trial the lack of trust is
actually coming from the same thing that
we talked about before the lack of trust
when every country needs to manipulate
their currency to drive the global jobs
agenda right then there's a total lack
of curve the lack of trust in Incan
currencies and to try to come back
together and say we're gonna fix that
globally right now I don't think there's
a chance and and that's actually didn't
that would play into why I'm really long
on Bitcoin because it's gonna happen no
matter what
yeah it almost feels like there's this
element of you get one of two options
right to solve the problem the first
option would be global coordination
where everyone trusts each other
we come together we create a new
standard view right off the old debt and
we move forward under Bretton Woods -
right or whatever you want to call it
but that involves complete trust of
everyone at the table to kind of Corbett
and agree together the other option is
trust no one
hey which essentially is what bitcoin is
and the trust no one option means
there's gonna be no one in control
there's gonna be no one in charge and
you actually don't need to trust anyone
else because you have the full
transparency to verify you know kind of
blocks etc and so you either get a
hundred percent trust or you get a
hundred percent you know no trust and I
think you're probably the same campus i
if like I just don't see the world where
everyone comes together and coordinates
and therefore that would suggest then
you end up in a world where trust no one
ends up being the dominate and kind of
approach yeah and if you play that play
that for so game theory predicts that
the sum of every one is better when
people quarry cooperate right
but what ends up happening is everyone
coordinated cooperating creates an
incentive for somebody to cheat right
and so as and so if you look at that
through through Bretton Woods or
anything else it even the paid changing
the gold reserve off the so everyone
cooperated worlds in a great place and
and then us can't pay Nemours and
everything else off the gold standard
and causing people not to cooperate as
as much for a while a fiat currency
backed all other world currencies for
80% of world currencies and it looked
like it was going but you started
manipulating at which point every other
currency has to manipulate to the one
has too many plates to have their jobs
erode as every other currency so and
that problem gets bigger and bigger and
bigger so if you look through game
theory what ends up happening is you
have you have cooperation and then then
no cooperation and then cooperation
again and no cooperation through a lens
of the world it's a simple example would
be driving in the carpool lane right if
everybody if the carpool lane is only
used for people who carpool it works
really well for people who carpool if a
lot of people cheat then incentive
accrues to those people who cheat and
then if nobody catches those people who
cheat everybody cheats then there's no
carpool advantage right so is hope
looking through this whole thing through
that through that lens and countries and
currencies and everything else was a
really important thing but I would
totally agree with you I cannot see it's
a it's a small possibility but it's it's
improbable the government's today this
far away from from cooperation could
come together and cooperate on a global
scale that needs to happen to be able to
prevent kind of a reset yeah so it's
pretty crazy world we're living in
what's the one thing that would change
your mind like is there something that
could happen that could change your mind
about you need to move into the
relation Airy world I don't think so so
if technology is deflationary and that's
not and when I say if it is clearly
deflation er it's that's not a guess
it's a fact and if technology is moving
into every industry then then there's no
possible way that we can run an
inflationary world anymore without
jerry-rigging a system and that's what
we're seeing right it's it's that's why
I say that it's way more important let's
just talk about this is talk about the
changes that are that have happened and
rebuild a society that works better for
everybody using what's what the facts
are clearly pointing out yeah it's it's
really interesting things I think that
there's the structural challenges right
obviously which you've out laid in terms
of where we are why it's unsustainable
and then it's very clear as to where we
need to go the big question mark I think
is that transition period right yeah and
on the transition period I just don't
see one route where there's no social
unrest right I don't see like an orderly
transition and that's the part that I
think a lot of people are just like how
do we do that
and the answer is they keep coming to
make them uncomfortable yeah
so and I think that's but that is the
truth
right so so if if deflation is is it is
is in our future if what if I what if
what I said how people look deeper read
the book you could debate that fact and
everything else and and prove me wrong
on that I can't see any any world
worried about it isn't true but I'm
happy to debate that the other thing is
it's just started it's going to get way
worse
if you think about think about how many
people that are working from home now
will stay working from home right think
about what that looks like
think about the acceleration to digital
that's happening right now out of kovat
and and how that accelerates retail
store closures how that accelerates a
whole pile of industries commercial real
estate that might not be made to price
where it is because it's not needed as
much so it's a it's it's all over the
place in every part of society but if
that's a fact and I think it's a pretty
clear fact then then let's talk about
what the solution looks like in that
because if you need to protect people's
way of wages and though then you don't
think to juice those people's wages to
protect I'm a staggering amount of debt
that you created in the first place
right if if you don't need to pay them
more to keep up with the treadmill that
you put them on in the first place right
wouldn't that be a good thing so so next
next year instead of your your mars bar
costing $90 it cost 90 cents in the year
after that 80 cents and everything else
and you're following isn't that a good
thing for society
um there's a there's this misconception
about economics and P didn't people put
their head in the sand with economics
because they think it's too complicated
and here's the thing a lot of that
economists make it too complicated
trying to explain things that just
clearly aren't there and and and and
that scares people from asking they were
the first principle type of type of
questions economics isn't about value
it's about scarcity right the air you
breathe is the most important thing in
your life right now you don't pay for it
right you pay for it if you go diving
underwater where air is skimmers you pay
you might pay for it and in Vegas Rove
area if it's if there's lots of smoke in
the air or if there's polluted but you
don't pay for area or because it's
abundant and free and you can create
economic model
about Eric where where there's abundance
technology creates abundance everywhere
right and and so so and that's a good
thing for society we should Lao we
should we should be celebrating yeah
it's this crazy thing where there's a
separation between what sounds to be the
right same kind of prudent thing and the
thing that everyone's drunken addicted
to right and that's ultimately what it
ends up coming down to yeah yeah that's
how you you do set up it's it's a hit of
cocaine right and you need a bigger hit
every time to think eventually the
patient dies yeah before we wrap up I
always do rapid-fire questions what uh
what's your most controversial thought
in either technology or or finance yeah
controversial and finances is this one
that in technology AI is going to
effectively speed and rate of growth
growth of AI yeah it's gonna be smarter
than all of us or creative or everything
else it's logical Paden every single job
is a function of it intelligence so how
could you get more jobs if you if a is
gonna be smarter than all of us how long
does that take low case the the top
researchers are saying five years I
think it's gonna be a longer 40 years
but the whole trend across that
landscape is all going to be deflation
err right because it's gonna be more and
more and more the entire entire time
exponentially more the entire time but
they say it's a hundred years it doesn't
matter by the time frame so if that if
that is going to happen which is going
to happen then then then then we have to
rebuild society to for it anyways yeah
what's the the best book you've ever
read other than your own
[Laughter]
I love thinking fast and thinking slow
just because it forces you to I made a
whole bunch of mistakes in reading the
book they take you through and it forces
you to realize that ask questions that
you might not have asked yourself before
and kind of finally find blind spots in
your own critical thinking this is a
Daniel pink I believe for you Daniel
Kahneman Daniel Kahneman okay I got it
very cool believer in aliens yes no yeah
so it would say say do I believe in
another do I believe in life on other
worlds yes I guess so yeah it'd be hard
to say on how many of the worlds does to
say no what is the logic for believing
that there is other life I'm with you I
just wonder what the logic is the amount
or the amount of the amount of planets
and solar sand stars in our solar system
it's just illogical to think that there
isn't like somewhere else you know when
you first said aliens I was thinking
about people visiting earth yeah well so
I've asked this question 260 270 people
whatever has been now and over 95% of
people say yes you know I believe in
something being out there etc which is a
much higher percentage than I would have
guessed before I started to ask everyone
that question yeah you you ask a whole
bunch of people that look at probability
distributions and and and if you looked
at the probabilities with that many
planets would be impossible to say know
exactly what on what one question do you
have for me to to finish up more but
they're not a question more of a
statement keep doing what you're doing
like this it's a it means a lot right
now it's really a really important work
and I didn't write the book I don't need
I don't need a book sale so I didn't
write the book for any reason to so but
somebody who they're like you with your
what you're doing makes a huge
difference to it can make a huge
difference to what's happening so
and I appreciate that as I tell people
what started out as me doing a bunch of
learning has now turned into there's a
sense of responsibility to some degree
right to kind of continue to share what
a what I think in and I'm learning so
it's a it's a weird world we're living
in because I don't think I ever expected
to be in this position but here we are
as I'm sure you didn't expect to write a
book at some point right exactly
absolutely all right well guys I hope
that you guys enjoyed this please go get
the book the price of tomorrow why
deflation is the key to the abundant
future obviously there's a number of
really important ideas in there and I
think that Jeff's done a great job so I
appreciate you jumping on here and I
want to do it again as as that world
becomes more of a reality awesome thanks
all right sir